hetzen verletzten töten immer mehr
extremisten werden in deutschland zu
tätern
die meisten kommen aus dem ganz rechten
lager hotelstadt fahrerkabine die eu
verbessert die arbeitsbedingungen von
fernfahrern und sorgt damit trotzdem bei
vielen für unmut zuviel smartphone
gerade jetzt in corona zeiten fürchten
eltern ihre kinder könnten süchtig und
krank werden
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend wir kommen bei
unseren nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
donnerstag den sport darin präsentiert
norbert lehmann anscheinend auch von mir
später in der schule halten kein problem
aber wir beginnen mit einer entwicklung
jetzt die der verfassungsschutz im
letzten jahr beobachtet hat extremismus
und gewaltbereitschaft nehmen exorbitant
zu zwar auch bei linksextremen aber die
weitaus meisten hassverbrechen kommen
von ganz rechts innenminister seehofer
nennt dies eine schande für unser land
laut verfassungsschutzbericht ist die
rechtsextreme szene in deutschland
deutlich größer geworden
innerhalb eines jahres stieg die zahl
der rechtsextremisten von etwa 24.000
auf mehr als 32.000 unter anderem auch
weil der rechtsnationale flügel der afg
in der statistik auftaucht die details
jetzt von klaus brodbeck
dieser bericht hat es in sich
noch nie war die gefahr von rechts so
groß wie heute
die zahl der delikte die zahl der
angehörigen zu diesem rechtsextremen
personenkreis und die zahl der
gewaltbereiten
rechtsextremisten ist weiter gestiegen
rechte gewalt eskaliert der mord an
walter lübke der anschlag auf die
synagoge in halle
die attentate von hanau hemmschwellen
sinken die täter sind der leibhaftig
gewordene hass dem internet viele
realwelt forciert und sich gegen
minderheiten und andersdenkende richtet
im visier auch weiterhin teile der afg
vor allem der sogenannte flügel der
verfassungsschutz geriert sich da als
gesinnungs gehilfe eines linken
zeitgeistes man will kritiker einer
ungehemmten masseneinwanderung
politischen mundtot machen
seit jahren bauen bund und länder ihre
sicherheitsbehörden aus und um gegen
jeden extremismus besonders intensiv
aber gegen rechts die opposition
verlangten mehr zusammenarbeit und
prävention
was wir brauchen um das zu tun um
extreme bewegungen besser zu bekämpfen
ist eine bessere zusammenarbeit der
sicherheitsbehörden auf allen ebenen der
behörden des bundes und der länder viele
relevante projekte kämpfen jedes jahr um
ihre förderung das muss verstetigt
werden wir brauchen klare finanzielle
zusagen aber auch linksextremisten
agieren immer gewalttätiger und vor
islamistischem terror wird weiter
gewarnt insgesamt die bedrohung bleibt
hoch der verdacht wiegt schwer
hessens innenminister peter beuth cdu
schließt ein rechtes netzwerk in der
polizei seines bundeslandes nicht mehr
aus ein sonderermittler soll jetzt
sowohl die drohungen gegen die
fraktionschefin der linken im landtag
janine wissler als auch die gegen eine
frankfurter rechtsanwältin vor zwei
jahren aufklären
in beiden fällen waren daten aus polizei
computer abgefragt worden
susanne santina berichtet
das letzte von insgesamt vier schreiben
hat die linken-politikerin janine
wissler erst am montag bekommen
alle waren mit nsu 2.0 unterzeichnet
genauso wie die drohungen die vor zwei
jahren die nsu anwältin sc dabei
schildes erhielt wie bei ihr wurden auch
die daten von karin wessler von einem
polizeicomputer ohne dienstlichen grund
abgefragt innenminister peter beuth
schließt nun ein rechtes netzwerk bei
der hessischen polizei nicht mehr aus
dass nach der unsäglichen bedrohung der
frankfurter rechtsanwältin und des zuvor
erfolgten daten abruft auf einem polizei
rechner in frankfurt nun abermals im
zeitlichen zusammenhang mit einer
solchen droh-mail eine datenabfrage auf
einem polizei rechner erfolgt ist nährt
den verdacht
vor zwei jahren wurden im zusammenhang
mit den drohungen gegen die nsu anwältin
ermittlungen gegen sechs polizeibeamte
in frankfurt aufgenommen die in einer
whatsapp gruppe rechtsradikale
botschaften verbreitet hatten
mittlerweile wird in hessen gegen
insgesamt 70 polizeibeamte ermittelt wir
haben die morde in hanau in jüngster
zeit die ermordung von lüpke im letzten
jahr und eine ausweitung sozusagen auch
innerhalb der polizei von rechten
strukturen und netzwerke und ich fordere
den minister auf hier seine endlich
seine arbeit zu tun und für aufklärung
zu sorgen
auch bundesinnenminister seehofer zeigte
sich heute alarmiert der fall selbst ist
vollkommen inakzeptabel und der muss ja
rücksichtslos aufgeklärt werden
unabhängig davon wir betroffen ist wie
der ist die hessische polizei diesmal
beamte aus wiesbaden in einen
rechtsradikalen vorfall verwickelt neben
minister beugt kündigte einen sondern
klar jetzt zur deutschen wirtschaft und
zucchero naschte pandemie hat den
ausnahmen auch im mai schwer getroffen
geschlossene grenzen und unterbrochenen
lieferketten haben spuren hinterlassen
laut statistischem bundesamt brachen die
ausfuhren im vergleich zum vorjahr um
fast 30 prozent ein
somit wurden im mai waren im wert von
80,3 milliarden euro exportiert im
vergleich zum april verbesserten sich
die exportzahlen aber leicht um 9% und
nun von den export zu den aktuellen
corona fallzahlen in deutschland hier
ist die zahl der neuinfektionen leicht
gesunken im schnitt der vergangenen
sieben tage haben sich 400 menschen
täglich neu mit dem virus angesteckt
gestern lag die zahl noch bei 420
deutschland hat das virus derzeit ganz
gut im griff doch weltweit steigen die
zahlen zum teil rasant
auch in europa vor allem auf dem balkan
wie in bulgarien
die meisten fälle gibt es jedoch immer
noch in amerika die usa und brasilien
sind am stärksten betroffen
doch auch mexiko zählte allein gestern
rund 7000 neuinfektionen in asien ist
indien das land mit den meisten fällen
fast 25.000 neue infizierte innerhalb
eines tages in afrika wird insgesamt
wenig getestet
außer in südafrika dort ist die lage
dramatisch im schnitt gibt es täglich
9000 neue fälle sandra menschen warten
vor einer klinik in soweto als das
personal plötzlich das tor schließt
unter tränen ruft eine krankenschwester
wir sind überfordert eine von uns ist
gestorben was sollen wir nur tun
am schlimmsten bietet die pandemie
derzeit in der provinz gauteng mit ihrer
hauptstadt johannesburg viele
krankenhäuser stoßen an ihre grenzen
auch dass barack obamas krankenhaus in
soweto ein pfleger der nicht erkannt
werden möchte berichtet von missständen
dort es gibt nicht genug
schutzausrüstung das hier ist eine n95
maske man sagt uns wir sollen diese
maske 50 7 tage tragen wenn wir genug
schutzausrüstung hätten müsst mir so
eine maske nicht mehrfach benutzen
[Musik]
landesweit haben sich tausende ärzte und
krankenschwestern infiziert besonders
schlimm ist die lage am ost kap
aufnahmen aus dem livingston krankenhaus
in nelson mandela bay
es fehlt an allem betten
beatmungsgeräten und personal
die krankenhäuser sind nicht mehr in der
lage die flut der patienten zu behandeln
was wir sehen und ich bin mir sicher
dass das wirklich passiert ist dass
menschen im krankenhaus sind und sterben
während sie auf hilfe warten
das ist tragisch aber wir wissen dass
das passiert wenn wir diese berichte
lesen
experten fürchten dass auch in
johannesburg bald betten und sauerstoff
fehlen werden die provinzregierung
scheint wenig optimistisch sie lässt am
rande der stadt bereits massengräber
ausheben
übertragen wird das virus ja
hauptsächlich durch tröpfcheninfektion
da stellt sich die frage wie hoch ist
das risiko durch die sogenannten
aerosole diese winzigen unsichtbaren
flüssigkeits tröpfchen die sich mit der
atemluft in räumen verbreiten können ob
schule oder büro reicht da abstand
halten
dieser frage sind wissenschaftler
nachgegangen stephanie heim
hier ist es theaternebel doch davon
gehen wissenschaftler aus er verhält
sich ähnlich wie euro soll partikel der
atemluft würde hier ein corona
infizierter atmen würden die viren mit
schweben das birgt gefahren
gerade in geschlossenen räumen wo gerade
luftzirkulation ist besteht durchaus die
möglichkeit dass sich jemand auch
minuten nachdem ihn eine andere person
platz verlassen hat sich in dieser rosa
wolke mit sauerstoff 2 infiziert hat
weil nachgewiesen worden ist das eben in
diesen euro sollen auch ausreichend
virus drin sein kann um andere menschen
zu infizieren
ich bin selbst bei normaler büro
belüftung wie hier das haben ingenieure
der tu berlin nachgewiesen wabern teile
der womöglich wären belasteten wolke
bald in jeder ecke
wenn ich eine einzelne person in einem
sehr großen raum mit einer guten
belüftung habe dann ist das risiko sehr
sehr gering wenn ich ein kleines büro
habe zwei personen darin eine davon ist
infiziert dann ist das risiko für die
andere person in den meisten fällen sehr
sehr hoch ein lösungs baustein so die
wissenschaftler co2 messgeräte steigt
die co2 konzentration wurde also schon
viel ausgeatmet können
und auch viele aerosol partikel mit
viren in der luft sein
indem ich möglichst die luft mit einer
geringen dosen konsumation haare also
ein ohne frischluft anteil
das zweite ist eben die aufenthaltsdauer
wie lange darf ich mich dann in dem raum
aufhalten und das ebenso kurz wie
möglich
klimaanlagen sorgen nicht immer für
ausreichend frischluft sagen sie an der
tu in berlin und weit aufgerissene
fenster helfen am besten wenn das zu
kräftigem durchzug führt für den us
präsidenten ist es eine niederlage
donald trump kann seine steuerunterlagen
nicht mehr komplett unter verschluss
halten
das oberste gericht entschied jetzt dass
die staatsanwaltschaft von new york ein
blick in trumps papiere nehmen darf
anders als andere us präsidenten hat
sich trump ja bisher geweigert seine
steuererklärungen offenzulegen was immer
wieder für spekulationen sorgt er habe
etwas zu verbergen
ein leben in der fahrerkabine immer auf
achse und weit weg von der familie die
arbeitsbedingungen von fernfahrern zu
verbessern eigentlich eine gute idee
doch viele fahrer und speditionen wollen
das gar nicht so ist in europa ein
streit entbrannt den ost europäern geht
es in erster linie und gutes geld im
harten trucker legen leben
die westeuropäer wollen dagegen höhere
preise und standards das eu parlament
hat nun ein reformpaket geschnürt das
ziel gleicher lohn für gleiche arbeit am
gleichen ort mehr details hat wundertüte
die a2 bei potsdam gewerkschafter
michael wahl berät lkw fahrer aus
osteuropa polnisch tschechisch ungarisch
kroatisch buga wie vor die kamera will
keiner deutsche fahrer sehen sie mit
konkurrenz angst und mitleid für
behandeltes gaben müssen im fahrzeug
laufen müssen und vorsichtiger werden
schlecht bezahlt die eu will das ändern
fahrer haben nun einen anspruch auf eine
heimfahrt eine drei wochen
und sie haben auch eine pflicht dazu
alle acht wochen die heute beschlossenen
regeln lassen aber lücken so kann zum
beispiel ein fahrer aus polen neue
ladung in deutschland und belgien
aufnehmen und sie nach frankreich
bringen und doch erhält er nur
polnischen lot bislang so der
gewerkschafter hatte etwa dieser fahrer
anspruch auf deutschen mindestlohn in
seinem fall heißt das einfach so eine
situation wird durch dieses
gesetzespaket massiv verschlechtert
soziale standards stehen gegen den
freien wettbewerb auch in brüssel auch
in derselben fraktion war nämlich
mitgliedstaaten hier sehr darauf bedacht
waren die grauzonen beizubehalten um
letztendlich ihrem sektor auch das
sozialdumping zu ermöglichen
ich denke nicht dass das sozialdumping
ist sagt dieser bulgarische
sozialdemokrat und kontert die neuen
regeln beschränken den binnenmarkt und
schließen osteuropäische fahrer aus
bulgarien will wegen der pflicht zur
heimfahrt nun klage einreichen die neuen
regeln ein kompromiss mit dem niemand
richtig glücklich ist
bei siemens haben die aktionäre das
vorerst letzte kapitel im konzernumbau
abgesegnet die energiesparte des
münchner industrieriesen wird
eigenständig
künftig gibt es dann drei siemens
gesellschaften an der börse siemens mit
dem digital und dem zug bereich die
medizin sparte siemens infineon und
siemens energy siemens chef joe kaeser
hatte damit geworben dass die einzelnen
kleineren unternehmen flexibler und
schneller würden
das smartphone ist aus unserem leben
nicht mehr wegzudenken wir telefonieren
und fotografieren
checken mails und surfen im internet in
der korona zeit hat der smartphone
konsum vor allem bei kindern und
jugendlichen noch mal dramatisch
zugenommen wie eine studie zeigt mit
gesundheitlichen folgen für die
heranwachsenden wilhelm tacke keine
schule kontaktsperre langeweile während
der korona krise rückte auch für bunnys
und seinen freund nick das smartphone
noch mehr in den mittelpunkt die
ablenkung durch die digitalen medien hat
den alltag in den familien erleichtert
aber auch für streit gesorgt 8 uhr ab
ins bett handy aus oder switches dann
gab es natürlich auch manchmal konflikte
wo er gesagt ich muss morgen nicht in
die schule
ich kann auch mal bis 9 auf bleiben und
weiter spielen mein freund laut einer
studie der kaufmännischen krankenkasse
hannover fand die mehrheit der eltern
die verstärkte nutzung von smartphones
okay mit der normalisierung der lage
kommen die sorgen zurück die größte
sorge der eltern in bezug auf die
gesundheit der kinder ist die medien
sucht also die abhängigkeit vom handy
dicht gefolgt von von mangelnder
bewegung also zu wenig bewegung und auch
konzentrationsstörungen und anderen
psychischen auswirkungen die sorgen
scheinen berechtigt schon vor krone hat
die krankenkasse einen anstieg und
typische erkrankungen bei kinder und
jugendlichen im alter von sechs bis 18
jahren festgestellt bei schlafstörungen
um rund 30 prozent bei motorischen
entwicklungsstörungen um rund 50 und bei
sprach- und sprechstörungen um 56,5
prozent ein ratschlag für die eltern ist
es wichtig dass die handynutzung
smartphone-nutzung keine monokultur wird
sondern dass man viele verschiedene
dinge in seinem leben macht von sport
über digitale medien nutzung bis hin zum
buch lesen darüber hinaus ist es wichtig
dass man sich immer auf eine sache
konzentrieren
wichtig ist laut studie vor allem dass
die eltern bei der nutzungsdauer
altersgerechte regeln aufstellen in
japan hoffen die menschen verzweifelt
auf ein ende des heftigen regens doch
dass es nicht in sicht seit samstag
haben mehr als 60 menschen ums leben
einige werden noch vermisst nachdem
zunächst nur der süden betroffen war
reißen
überschwemmungen und schlammlawinen nun
auch in zentraljapan häuser und straßen
mit
hunderttausende bewohner sind
aufgefordert wird zuhause zu verlassen
noch bis mindestens sonntag soll es
weiter regnen
ja und nun zum sport norbert und zum
geplanten neustädter neustart der
deutschen handballbundes liegen genau da
haben sich die 39 vereine wirklich was
vorgenommen
am ersten oktober soll es losgehen und
zwar mit publikum in den hallen und
einem hygiene konzept das auch andere
sportarten wie basketball und eishockey
übernehmen könnten
in handball hallen ist infektionsschutz
ungleich komplizierter als unter freiem
himmel wenn hunderte lautstärke fans in
einem geschlossenen raum sind deshalb
hat die liga konkrete pläne im blick das
war natürlich abstandsregeln einhalten
das mit mundschutz gearbeitet wird wo
wir tickets nachverfolgen können im fall
einer infektion dass wir auf diese leute
zugehen können wird das hygiene konzept
vom bundesgesundheitsministerium
genehmigt müssen die klubs ist lokal
umsetzen und die fans sich daran halten
um jede einzelne halle corona handball
tauglich zu machen kompliziert fakt ist
aber handball braucht zuschauer bei den
füchsen berlin zum beispiel bringen die
fans in normalen zeiten ein viertel der
einnahmen auf dauer werden damit
zuschauern spielen müssen sonst wird
profi handball profi basketball profi
alles okay nicht finanzierbar sei das
sind ambitionierte pläne in der hoffnung
nicht noch einmal einen saison abbrechen
und einen masten meisterehren zu müssen
eindrucksvoller protest im
nordamerikanischen fußball vor dem
restart der profiliga mls in orlando
versammelten sich gestern abend die
schwarzen spieler aller 25 teams um ein
zeichen gegen rassismus und
polizeigewalt zu setzen es ist eine
choreografie in zwei teilen die
schwarzen spieler aller teams stehen am
rande des platzes gruppiert nach
mannschaften sie recken die rechte faust
gen himmel die klassische black power
geste gegen rassistische diskriminierung
sind trotz einiger corona bedingten
absagen mehr als 100 dazu im mittelkreis
aller akteure des ersten spiels dieses
turniers mit dem die nach zwei
spieltagen unterbrochene saison
fortgesetzt wird
diese spieler knien eine geste gegen
polizeigewalt bekannt geworden durch den
american football-spieler calling panik
dauer der demonstration acht minuten 47
sekunden exakt so lange wie george floyd
durch polizisten zu tode gedrückt wurde
das turnier findet wegen des corona
virus für alle teams in orlando florida
statt
danke
jetzt haben wir noch einen ganz
besonderen radweg für sie diese hügelige
piste im bayrischen kirchdorf an der
amper fünf buckel auf 500 metern kein
planungsfehler sondern so gewollt als
sogenannte erlebnis radweg weil der im
überschwemmungsgebiet der amper liegt
wäre der bau einer ebenen fahrbahn
deutlich teurer geworden
geringere kosten also und mehr spaß für
die ganze familie
sieht lustig aus zum wetter da gibt es
morgen viel regen und kräftige gewitter
zu den einzelheiten gleich gunther
tiersch so viel von uns schön dass sie
dabei waren
marietta slomka um drei viertel 10 mit
dem heute-journal und einem interview
mit dem verfassungsschutz präsidenten
thomas haldenwang und hier freut sich
morgen wieder der barbara hahlweg auf
sie noch einen entspannten abend für sie
und machen es gut
[Musik]
die zuschauer morgen gibt es an den
alpen mal heftigen regen zum teil mit
starken gewittern
wir haben ja derzeit so ein kleines
tiefdruckgebiet an der nordsee und das
zieht jetzt unter verstärkung richtung
ostseeküste und es lenkt dahinter eben
diese kühle luft nach deutschland am
wochenende erreicht hier auch die alpen
aber vorher gibt's eben diesen
starkregen morgen und zum teil
diese heftigen gewittern heute nacht
wird es auf jeden fall leicht regnen
norddeutschland weiterhin aber morgens
früh wird dagegen etwas stärker 8 grad
sind es dann in schleswig holstein im
südwesten 19 gerade so fasst eine
tropische nacht und tagsüber sind die
temperaturgegensätze noch größer 14 15
grad sind nur noch an der nordsee aber
im südöstlichen bayern bis zu 32 grad
und es wird erst mal regnen
norddeutschland morgen zum teil nach
osten hin auch mal mit blitz und donner
sonst beginnt der tag allerdings noch
ziemlich sonnig nachmittags ändert sich
das im süden immer mehr schauer und
gewitter entstehen zum teil eben
unwetterartig mit starkregen hagel
sturmböen norden gibt es weitere schauer
am nachmittag könnte vielleicht an der
nordsee dann mehr und mehr die sonne
wieder rauskommen wird dieser recht
kräftige starke nordwestwind dazu ja der
samstag bringt dann noch dauerregen hier
an den alpen aber sonntag montag es wird
sonnig und langsam auch wieder wärmer
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut